would you work with us in terms of what
regulations you think are necessary in
your industry
absolutely Mark Zuckerberg is the multi
billionaire founder and CEO of Facebook
and this week he testified before
Congress assuring lawmakers that his
company will play nice with government
regulators Richard Hendricks Richard
Hendricks from HBO's Silicon Valley is
the bumbling CEO of the unfortunately
named Pied Piper his memorable moments
include evacuating his bowels vomiting
and then lunging into a glass wall in
front of all of his workers one is
poised when being grilled by Congress
the other can't even deliver a pep talk
to his staff without hurling under his
desk but our better hope for the future
of the Internet is with Richard
Hendricks and not Mark Zuckerberg and
here's why we need to take a more
proactive role in a broader view of our
responsibility it's not enough to just
build tools we need to make sure that
they're used for good
in his testimony Zuckerberg welcomed
regulation and even agreed to help craft
it Mark Zuckerberg is in the same
position as the late 19th century
railroad tycoons contrary to
conventional wisdom these robber barons
embraced regulation as a way to raise
the barriers to entry for competitors
who were eating into their profits and
market share still sporting a hoodie
Richard Hendricks is at an earlier stage
of his career he's trying to build a new
Internet in an effort to outmaneuver
hooli a fictional amalgamation of Google
and Facebook hooli is the future even
Richards specific approach to disrupting
Facebook is more than just TV fantasy we
could build a completely decentralized
version of our current internet with no
firewalls
no tolls no government regulation no
spine information would be totally free
in every sense of the word
Richard represents the next wave of
innovation the competitor who if
Congress and the government stays out of
it will eventually erode Facebook's
market share by offering a better
product when you add more rules that
companies need to follow that's
something that a larger company like
ours inherently just has the resources
to go do and that might just be harder
for a smaller company getting started to
be able to comply with there's a
real movement in the tech world to build
a new decentralized web that would give
users actual control over their own data
and create open platforms that aren't
controlled by any single all-powerful
CEO one reason to bet on these real-life
projects to decentralize the internet
projects like Lock Stock and etherium is
that talented engineers are beating down
their doors because working at Google
and Facebook is lucrative but it's also
soul-killing we've been given the
opportunity to rewrite the most
important thing in human history and we
can build it the way it should have been
made all alone you know not this shitty
addictive parasite that companies like
hooli used to spy on us and exploit us
as Facebook and Congress start to write
new rules for cyberspace all of us who
believe in free expression and
permissionless innovation have a real
stake in making sure that the future of
the Internet remains as wide open and
uncharted as possible